[Music]
what is going on there reject nation we
got ourselves five new tv spots for the
batman that supposedly include plenty of
new footage take a batarang to that like
button people can't wait for this movie
comes out in like a month oh my god it's
so soon it's almost here i can't believe
it can't believe we've been hearing a
lot of things about this film and
perhaps we'll touch on some details that
the cast has recently been talking about
as well let's just swing into action and
see what we got today
[Music]
fear
is a tool
they think i'm hiding in the shadows
watching
waiting to strike
but i am the shadows
oh man
he delivers those lines so well
i am the shadows
the batman
he's trailers
why is he writing to you
[Music]
it's all about the wings
you'd be surprised but even a good man
is kick carbide hey whoa it had like pov
shot
my whole life
wow
maybe this is all coming to an end
the batman
there's a lot of new stuff in that yeah
got this about a king compressors to
match
maybe this is all coming to an end
god damn right yeah you are
that shot love the way they're doing all
this aerial stuff scared me with that
mask in that cave
it's nice to actually get some carbide
before you've nothing left i don't care
what happens to me
what are we looking for
i'm vengeance
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
i've always
loved the music in all these spots man
yeah
all these drops
bro
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know stop it delany
what are you hiding
[Music]
oh wow
wow looks like those were great those
were like really
solid short trailers today i really hope
every scene with the penguin involves
him getting beat up by batman's car
i'm just genuinely loving how haunting
and menacing batman himself is feeling
you know it's so interesting hearing
what some of the early reactions have
been for the movie as well as what the
cast especially with robert pattinson
has been talking about lately saying how
this is like an unusual film that it's
not what you're probably expecting and
that it's a little bit more sad than
what you'd be expecting too especially
watching these five spots back to back
the feeling doesn't ignite in me of the
hero batman what i get in here is the
threat the menacing threat that lurks in
the shadows as he says in the trailer he
is the shadows remember in like bvs the
first time you see the the criminals
that uh when the cops are going in there
and that afflicts batman's kind of at
the the top corner of the ceiling that
right there of like this is the thing
that the criminals fear that's what this
feels like but the entire time the handy
circus was saying robert pattinson does
such a great job at this like almost
jekyll and hyde thing with the character
he's two completely different people
when he's bruce wayne versus batman and
they keep showing this one moment of
maybe it's just a good trailer line but
they keep showing this one moment robert
pattinson saying you lied to me alfred
and from what andy serkis was revealing
himself was that their relationship
starts off really strained where alfred
struggles to be the father figure that
he strives for to be in bruce's life but
you know bruce just keeps pulling away
from him and is going down this path
which is very you know bruce to do and
i've been hearing like it's it's complex
and that's going to be making some
choices that will probably challenge the
audience so good one last thing i was
expecting was you know something that
could potentially border on divisive i
wasn't that's the last thing i was
anticipating but it sounds like this is
going to be something that is not the
fun superhero movie at all
yeah while there's going to be a lot of
badassery to it that it's really going
to be quite introspective on all the
characters like every character here
especially from what colin farrell was
talking about with zoe kravitz has been
saying what what paul dana was talking
about too like paul dana was saying that
for the riddler it was more than just
pulling from comics it was about
embodying what gotham is like really
feeling what the city of gotham is and
being reflective of that he does have a
political agenda watching how this is
all gonna unfold like this this just
seems like brutal and unsettling like
it's just gonna get under your skin i
don't know i mean to me that just sounds
like a perfect pep in movies
it does well and it sounds something
akin to and not to say that any of the
previous or that many of the previous
batman movies haven't felt like this but
yeah it feels very akin to some of those
broader more expansive graphic novels
that you get to yeah spend a lot of time
in with the characters but also with the
action yeah like the way that they're
drawing just the overall vibe of gotham
it feels like an affliction that
everyone has to live with yeah everyone
is struggling against no matter whether
it's the street punks or the politicians
or bruce himself i love the way that
even in these trailers you get that
duality of it looks completely badass
and completely brutal and completely
dark in a cool way but also really
emotionally heavy and warped and
anguished and strained and strange
and yeah i love the idea that you have
what appears to be a really gripping
action thriller but also a really harsh
emotional drama and i get that vibe
increasingly with every trailer even
though the trailers are really uh focal
about you know the physical aspects the
action the different colorful characters
showing up but yeah even getting more of
carmine falcone here like i i like that
they're slowly creeping in more of that
political gender agenda and the
political sort of stratosphere that
gotham exists within and if you guys
don't know what carmine falcone is he's
uh he's basically like modbus yeah he
runs a lot of continents you know you've
got all that fun stuff oh how are all
the different characters going to
interact but what's most exciting is
that you know sort of personal i want to
know what personal conversation batman
and the ruler are going to have what
does the riddler know about bruce wayne
what does he know about his family and i
imagine there's going to be a lot of
incredible eye acting yes
because as much as we want like the
white eyes considering just how much the
promotions for this film keep him
primarily in the suit it makes me think
that he'll be in the suit for like most
of this movie versus him being bruce
wayne predominantly and then some of the
time he's batman primarily relying on
body language and just his eyes and if
anyone can bring so much depth and pain
and anguish to the eyes it's gonna be
robert pattinson he's a phenomenal actor
and you know what dude i gotta point out
the way they're utilizing even the
freaking batmobile even his car like
what i love is how everything feels and
rob hasn't talked about this too like
you could feel the seams within his suit
you can tell like everything is just
like a little bit more beaten down and
it's all rugged
diy yeah good way to put it even with
the with the batmobile which i think the
prequel novel unveiled that he built
that at like 16 years old or at least
building cars at 16 or something like
that with that batmobile that shot that
you have in there of it appearing and
the penguins staring it down like even
giving the batmobile a real presence
that oh my god look out for that car
it's also a character yeah it's awesome
it's so cool i don't know i mean if it
is a little bit divisive if it is like
it makes some choices that challenge
audiences i'm all for it man i mean
we've had like a gazillion batman
interpretations by this point bring on
something that challenges the audience a
little bit more why not guys leave your
thoughts down below what you think about
all this footage you can subscribe click
that bell hit that like button and hey
we will catch you guys soon